this morning we're learning how the
pandemic is stranding babies born to
surrogate mothers around the world
coronavirus travel restrictions make it
impossible for many parents to bring
those children home Holly Williams spoke
to an American family in the middle of
this ordeal in this clinic in Ukraine
there are dozens of babies waiting to be
claimed they were born via IVF to
surrogate mothers but after Ukraine
closed its borders in March many of
their biological parents can't get here
to be with their newborns Joel and
Michelle liner kee from Sacramento were
two months away from their daughter's
due date when Ukraine's borders were
sealed you know the worst fear was just
gonna be what are we facing and are we
not gonna see her till she's six months
old we've probably had a hundred couples
to come to us just for helping um in
getting to the children overseas every
home is a surrogacy facilitator who told
us he's helping several American couples
take a complicated land route into
Ukraine with special permission from the
authorities it's a dreadful situation
Joel left Michelle and their kids at
home and made the nearly 48 hour journey
to Ukraine walking across the border
from Belarus and then doing 14 days
quarantine making it out just in time
for the birth of their daughter in
Bahrain last week it's gonna be quite a
journey going back but I can't wait to
get home and miss my family it'll have
been just a day short of five weeks but
when I land and get to see them that's a
big world I'm ready for you I've got my
passport but a Ukrainian official says
there are over a hundred stranded babies
in her country whose parents haven't
been able to make it in Sam Everingham
believes there could soon be over a
thousand and the problem is mounting
because so many babies are born each
week while the rest the wolf stops
pregnancy
for CBS this morning Holly Williams such
a painful situation there and in fact I
have some window into that pain as a
parent with a ten-year-old and an
eight-year-old in Israel who I haven't
seen since December 31st they lived
there with their mother she's doing a
great job that but I've already missed
one visit they're supposed to come here
for the summer this virus we know it's a
killer but this piece also underscores
the fact and I know personally it's also
a divider it's a very tough situation
all around
for parents in that situation